foreign
to a money and Mental Health Report by
bank rate in partnership with psych
Central just under half of U.S adults
say that money has a negative impact on
their mental well-being that's true the
ability to provide for a household or
keep up with day-to-day expenses can
cause major stress stress pair these
responsibilities with the possibility of
a recession and record high inflation
and it's no surprise that many of us are
feeling the heat I like this setup
they're like trying to just like make us
all feel warm and fuzzy and like yeah
let's we're all afraid we're gonna give
you something good okay let me I just
want to tell you like so I for everybody
listening I want you to to to call this
out
anytime you read an article and it's
talking about one organization in
partnership with another
usually that means that somebody is
buying the authority of somebody else to
sell their product it's why it's uh
you'll see companies
um buy a professorship at a university
so they can do their quote-unquote
research for their r d for their
programs and they put all the negative
findings in a drawer and then they just
published all the all the all the
glorified stuff right just seeing this
it gets better I'm reaching for the
Preparation H go for it
luckily there are still ways we can take
control of our finances oh thanks
strategic use of financial tools like
credit cards can allow us to put our
money to work for us with this at our
disposal we can steadily chip away at
those money and mental health woes here
are five ways credit cards can improve
your mental health I just want to say to
my friends at psych Central you all
should be ashamed I don't even know what
you are but if you're under if you're if
you are about helping people you should
be ashamed of yourself bankrites just
doing what bank rate does they're trying
to sell credit and uh I mean you got a
rattlesnake in a bag I'm not going to be
mad at the real estate for trying to
bite me if I put my hand in there
but a mental health group if that's what
psych Central even is
this is just it's disgusting man yeah
it's gross well okay they got five tips
and even just reading it kind of made me
nauseous I'm like oh my goodness so the
first one is using it to pay down
existing credit card debt so basically
just switching things over taking
advantage of the zero percent APR
basically alleviating
your issue with another temporary
solution so they're lying to you now
they're saying they're paying down
credit card debt but all you're doing is
moving dead around yep and then the
second one this one is just this one's
kind of Epic it says plan a free or
heavily discounted vacation
y'all we're we're in we're in stress
we're feeling mental health issues
because of credit card debt so let's go
on vacation
oh man and let's hold on uh you should
pick a rewards card that best aligns
with your spending habits and use your
rewards earnings to cover cost
so we have record high inflation the
possibility of a recession we're really
feeling Financial stress what you should
do is spend just use the right card and
then go on a vacation
this is madness yeah it I mean and and
we've talked to a lot of people that are
doing their credit card rewards and all
of that and everybody thinks that
they're going to be able to be the
person that uses the rewards they never
go into debt but that's so sad that
we're literally talking to people who
are this article is talking to people
who are stressed out right they're
already in credit card debt they're
frustrated they're feeling inflation
they're feeling all these things and
it's like hey like let's why don't you
try this out well and let me tell you
this like and I've mentioned this on the
show before I used to have a card and I
paid it off every month I never had any
debt on it but I always I put all my
expenses in there and to just get free
flights I did all the time
and I got free flights I really did and
it occurred to me one day
this Airline company's not my friend so
there's got to be something else at play
here
and then the more I dug into it
oh it's that single mom who can't afford
food who's paying for my vacation with
her 32 APR fees
I'm not participating in that nonsense
because it's just squashing people who
are desperate who are struggling you are
hungry whose kids need shoes and they
get this kind of nonsense and then I get
a free flight out of that deal I'm out
of the system I'm gladly going to pay
for my flights
that are not going to be on the back of
somebody who doesn't can't afford to
make the payments does that make sense
absolutely I'm opting out man yeah I
literally just posted that yesterday I
was doing an interview and posted that
that's my same reasoning that it's like
I somebody in order for me to win with
points somebody else is losing that's
right and that's just so sad
um the other points are save on everyday
expenses which they're talking about
like cash back and basically making sure
you spend enough so you get cash back
which is kind of crazy when I was on
with George one day and he was doing the
math on like how much you'd actually
have to spend to get that free flight or
that amazing cash back and it was
ridiculous
um another point is build your credit
of course and then the last one is to
navigate the cost of a large purchase
they are suggesting to use credit cards
to navigate large purchases they
basically say that they talk about
emergency funds it says our Bankrate
survey cites insufficient emergency
savings is the leading cause of negative
impacts on Mental Health surrounding
money whether prepared or not
emergencies happen and they can be
costly a credit card can be a great tool
to have in your Arsenal to cover you in
a pinch you don't need an arsenal
you don't need an Arsenal you're not at
war with your life you just need an
emergency fund which means you need a
couple of years of really really
uncomfortable awful hard work not seeing
your family not seeing your friends not
eating restaurants like it just it sucks
I've been there man you've been like
it's not it's the worst yep and then on
the other side of it man I don't need an
Arsenal I don't I mean and I think
what's so what bothers me so much about
this article is it is it it's talking to
people like they're your friend like the
credit card company is your friend hey
you have a mental health struggle hey
you're feeling down inflation's getting
you we have a solution for you it's like
leading a sheep to the slaughter it's
like that is not the solution that is
like the opposite of what we're trying
to do here it's the opposite of how
we're trying to help people and it just
breaks my heart that there's somebody
who's feeling mental health struggles
right now and they're reading this
article going oh man like maybe that is
the answer and they're now going to be
calling us four year years from now with
seventy thousand dollars in credit card
debt yeah that's a bank rate in
partnership with with psych Central did
their study and uh here we are guys
speak to the mental health of somebody
who feels very fragile right now and
they're overwhelmed with their finances
and they don't have an emergency fund
and they feel frustrated like what would
you tell them if they read this article
right now what would you tell them to
help them go the other way
um
there oh geez there's so much here
ultimately this
um and I think I can make a pretty
compelling Neuroscience case if you owe
somebody money your brain is never going
to let you rest because even though your
frontal lobe knows and I don't get all
nerdy but your frontal lobe knows hey
that's a good deal that's zero percent
APR it's no payments for five years
whatever it's it I we can look at a
spreadsheet and call it a good deal
you're amygdala the part of your brain
that's designed to keep you safe is
going to sound the alarms and those
alarms might look like anxiety they
might look like depression they might
look like any number of things because
your brain knows and it's core core
being
that Toyota Motor companies deciding
what you do the more Discover card is
deciding what you do tomorrow not you
that you're not safe one little glitch
in The Matrix and you don't have food
because this other company is going to
say I want my money now and you're
paying for last month's rent this month
and you're paying for last month's food
this month
it's just a a nonsensical cycle that we
gotta stop you can't go into more debt
to solve your issues and I'll also say
there are some emerging research that's
really powerful that suggests
going through challenges heading into
the storm that's the way to mental
health healing and most of us can't do
it by ourselves as we talked about
earlier about getting a counselor get
somebody to walk alongside you getting a
group of friends that will walk with you
um but avoiding these things and trying
to hack your way to better Financial
Health or hack your way to better mental
health it's not how it works it's not
how it works you gotta take the long
difficult path
um and do it with other people and
that's the path to Healing